allez on va lancer l'épreuve Philippe
Etchebest comme d'habitude je vous
laisse le dernier mot qu'est-ce que vous
avez envie de dire à vos adversaires
fuyez
un peu friscount ce matin là non
s'il vous plaît ça va pas bien il fait
frais
alors
les températures se sont
allez-y donc les températures sont à peu
près ce matin
c'est ça qui est important pour moi même
pas me Picasso c'est quand même un grand
génie il a dit j'ai essayé toute ma vie
de dessiner comme un enfant donc si le
plus grand artiste peintre du monde il
dit faites sortez le gosse qui est en
vous faites sortez l'enfant Titan vous
kiffer
il y aura un petit peu de nuage un petit
bois de nuageux sur la Bretagne
heureusement que je vous ai écouté
depuis 6H30 les températures pour cet
après-midi alors ça c'est les débuts un
peu un peu couvert sur la Bretagne
donc également un peu d'instabilité sur
le sud-est du pays et puis je m'arrêter
ou non
vous verrez
physiquement moi par exemple ce qui va
me taper au premier regard c'est
le sourire de la fille
non
je la trouve extrêmement intelligente
et je trouve qu'elle ne dit que des
conneries les femmes qui doivent faire
le barbecue je trouve ça mais une
connerie beaucoup d'humour très
spirituel
et un président plus que médiocre elle
aussi je la trouve très intelligente
la suite elle je trouve qu'elle ne fait
que des conneries à Paris je me fais
chier dessus complet se faire faire caca
dessus par une mouette au premier date
c'est pas commun ça détend un petit peu
l'atmosphère
j'aurais préféré qu'elle se détende
autrement
vas-y il voulait tomber de maillot mais
il s'est à sa taille ben non moi le pire
binôme quoi moi tous les jours je lave
mes vêtements lui depuis le début de
l'aventure je l'ai jamais vu faire une
lessive ni prendre une douche à un
moment donné désolé une culotte ça ne se
prête pas à quelle heure ta saucisse
elle va rentrer dans mes culottes les
deux ensemble c'est vraiment une ode au
patriarcas je paierai pour les voir
participer aux amours
quand même beaucoup d'argent et
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
vous voyez je suis toujours obligé de le
faire taire
je n'attends pas du Black Bloc tu lui
parles réprimer sa violence en revanche
du policier du policier qui est formé
qui a un cadre légal et qui peut exercer
une violence extrêmement importante qui
peut aller jusqu'à la violence létale
d'une façon légale d'une façon légale je
légitime défense encore heureux
la bague police
ce sont des techniques de défense très
utile dans des situations délicates
parfait au niveau de la branche
avec leur vélo ultra léger 10 kg les
policiers s'en servent comme bouclier
face à des assaillants parfois dangereux
c'est plus un moyen de se défendre se
protéger
ça fonctionne le policier et il est
normal qu'il puisse excuse-moi
excuse-moi quand quelqu'un lui rouler
dessus il est normal qu'un Pol
icier pendant
pour toi
du moment où on ouvre la bouche non mais
tu vis dans le monde des bisounours le
policier sur le train de tenir comme toi
et moi ou une femme et Barbara
il coupe la parole alors attends
elles sont très mal organisées
tu es sous influence t'es matrixé il y a
la question de la gestion du stress et
la capacité
de ma formation politique
d'avoir été avec nous pour Poutine en
fait le fameux
[Musique]
le fameux carambach vous avez bien
entendu c'est packaging aux couleurs
acidulés reprennent à 6 méprendre le
design de célèbre marque de confiseries
carambach moule à barre ou encore cheat
coeurs ou Nutella vous avez oublié de
dire qu'il y avait du bébé mouton dans
votre soupe je sais pas ce que j'aurais
pu faire cuire autrement poulet je veux
dire quoi une chèvre
je crois que c'est le bébé d'un animal
aussi bref je vais aventurier dans mes
réflexion
marwache c'est une première l'homme et
la femme les plus riches au monde sont
tous les deux Français c'est le
classement Forbes pour 2023 qui le dit
il s'agit de Bernard Arnault président
fondateur de LVMH numéro 1 mondial du
luxe et de Françoise Bettencourt Meyers
héritière de L'Oréal AE2 il pèse près de
270 milliards d'euros sachez qu'aux
classement Elon Musk patron de Tesla ou
encore de Twitter et deuxième et Jeff
Bezos patron d'Amazon troisième quel
était votre plus grand souvenir à trois
ça ça peut être mal interprété
j'ai vu les US spring espiègle de
Nicolas derrière qui a cherché ce Jacky
en 10 secondes je me suis dit tout ça
est très mauvais
non je vous ai appelé comment Nicolas
voilà bah ouais mais je suis des années
90 les gars donc forcément
après par rapport à l'aventure je
pensais vraiment que tu allais cuisiner
une viande surprenante tu vois je me
vois pas faire cuire un singe dans mon
tajine non plus déjà de 1 je ne sais pas
cuisiner ça de deux je ne pense pas que
ça se mange et de trois je ne pense pas
que ça va ça aurait pu agrand monde ça
on ne le saura jamais puisque vous
n'avez pas pris ce risque et ça c'est un
fion pour une personne ou tu le partage